foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
news you need to know Tommy are you live
from the new Rockstar's headquarters
Nationwide my horse
has in the chat for all wow my horse Mr
thunderous was put down today after he
killed three other horses oh wow it was
charged with horse murder and after a
speedy horse trial he was horse-ecuted
[Music]
uh we salute you uh Mr 21-day salute
coming up on today's episode
uh what Geniuses could be helping the
Langs and the pins out of the quantum
realm the way you read it was just like
who are the ad Wizards a very deep SNL
what geniuses
sorry uh no no no no no that's accurate
uh we're gonna get into we might even
get Brandon to explain his uh slow Kang
Theory Maybe
he's um
and and I know I say this sometimes and
I'm often a bit of a blow hard and I'm
positive about everything on this show
but we have legitimately one of the best
segments that's ever been produced not
on the break room but on new rock stars
broadly I would say on on broadcast live
that's right on the internet and nay nay
[Applause]
NOW Watch Me Whip now watch me Nae Nae
uh all right yeah thank you for the dab
um yeah so we have one of the best
segments we're gonna we're gonna get to
it uh uh John and our production team
has put in a lot of work uh All I'm
gonna say I'm just gonna tease a little
bit oh wow did you watch Pedro Pascal
host SNL last weekend uh there were a
lot of fun sketches but there was one
that really kind of blew up it was Mario
meets Last of Us
I'm just gonna tease that yeah I'm just
gonna leave that there for you uh with
me here to do all of that of course
we've already introduced uh Thomas
Bechtel he previously of the horse
ownership uh We've also got uh usually
on screen but now on-screen producer
John Costa over there those three horses
were mine
oh no triple homicide and then
um uh the horse he wrote in on Brandon
Barrick hey you can catch me up there
clapping oh no
uh hey let's get into some headlines
yeah yeah
um of course we're in the thick of it
we're a week out almost exactly a week
out from Ant-Man otherwise quantumania
opening uh none of us have seen it yet
Tommy's actually scheduled to see it
pretty soon yeah uh the rest of us have
our tickets uh but we haven't seen it uh
one of our last amen Quantum media shows
probably yeah yeah we'll start going
yeah we're gonna try to work on it
pretty soon yes we had to kick Jessica
out of the studio yeah yeah because
she's taking it yesterday yeah so she
can't talk uh from an objection
oh no and she watched it on his phone
she's like I know it's on your phone
show it to me David Lynch hated that
um so uh Ant-Man was quantum Mania
producer Stephen brassard says that
talks for Ant-Man 4 are already
happening
quantumania what are they gonna add to
the title Ant-Man and the wasp and
Stinger or stature and old Ant-Man and
family and people and family persons
uh that is interesting that it seems
like Marvel with the sequels they always
get into the uh colons right like Colin
quantumania Colin Civil War colon uh
Ragnarok or whatever right like uh what
about Ant-Man and Uncle men
get out of here absolutely not um this
would be you know they've only done one
four set so far Thor yeah Thor got four
is what they say yes Captain America is
due to get his fourth well he's dead so
I don't know
the shield Civil War Captain America
movie it technically well Marvel did so
I stand by our overlords uh but yeah you
want our chips to blow up our inhibitor
chips framing to get four movies
especially when we were kind of talking
about this in the office like they have
the Old Guard is kind of going out and
they're putting in all these new young
actors and they don't have that kind of
like middle-aged actor range as much
anymore you want more middle-aged Heroes
more middle-aged Heroes Our Heroes need
to rub their bodies down with Icy Hot
and then gay afterwards yeah yeah
possible
ironic uh you know um Paul red who I
believe is 54. I think he's he's well
into his 50s on the older end but this
franchise I mean uh Evangeline Lilly is
younger than him and then course Cassie
is is that country they finally got
right according to the actors so they
the poor actors who played Cassie before
they're like Catherine Newton wow she's
incredible I don't know who those other
bags of Bones were but I hope they die
obviously but uh Stephen Broussard you
know went on to say that like The
Whispers have already started to happen
between myself and Peyton Peyton Reed
the director and Kevin being Kevin feige
um Henry must be like the easiest dude
you had to make another move no they're
probably not literal Whispers to me but
uh industry Whispers yeah we know they
have Hey Kevin
and they talked about and that was a
year ago maybe a nightmare plan at this
point but I'm sure that had some mapped
out continuous yeah I don't think this
conversation started this week right
it's probably been going on and now
though I do think even this conversation
maybe has some spoiler elements to it
because like does that mean Ant-Man
definitely survives this movie we're
getting another Captain America we're
getting a new Captain America movie yeah
that's true you can continue the Ant-Man
franchise even without Scott there's
thousands of Ant-Man running around to
my knowledge there is no Thunder in the
Thunderbolts movie so wow
um so interesting we could also assume
maybe Ant-Man or characters from this
franchise might show up in
um secret Wars definitely might show up
in King Dynasty right yeah so uh
certainly with with
um their connection already to Kang so
anyways we're interested to see probably
a lot of that will depend if this movie
makes a billion dollars there you go you
better believe they will start that
crank cranking
um uh also Stephen Broussard went on to
tease the future of horror in the MCU
saying we're starting to introduce some
cool characters that are in the darker
side the more Monster side and the
Supernatural and the Occult in a very
organic way as you're seeing these
characters pop up now do we think
we could see Ant-Man well yeah do we see
in a cult or a darker a spiritual kind
of character chaos coming around the
corner but do we think we see one of
those characters pop up and hit me on
the walls quantumania no during the
initial second for Dracula we saw that
clip today with the Broccoli Guy I don't
know does it count as a cult
some people would argue veganism is a
cult of its own I mean it's certainly
organic but they they moved the blade
release date but it's still on the
calendar yeah
2024. it's it's coming out after
Thunderbolts which was supposed to be
the end of face yeah it was originally
going to be November of this year now I
think it's bumped to November of next
year I believe birthday presents for me
obviously that will have like occult
elements to it yes and yes covet of
chaos would like to introduce stuff will
we see another special presentation of a
werewolf by night they gotta do them
every Halloween oh my God Jack Russell
people love him most of that movie was
special effects even man thing a lot of
him was special effects so like they
didn't have to spend months and months
and months and months doing CGI for that
you could shoot that when you see a
special effects being practical
specialist right right special effects
versus visual effects yeah well and one
one thing we're not going to get into
but I'm obsessed with is you know Bob
Iger actually right before he went live
just made this announcement at Disney
called us yeah on the phone with us in
thousands of reporters well Jessica
hasn't gone to his head he uh uh Bob
Iger the current CEO the former and
current CEO of Disney announced they're
gonna cut seven thousand jobs
um and they want to try to trim I think
it was three billion dollars a year in
content spend from the company now
that's a lot of money they spend about
30 billion dollars a year and that's
across films Disney plus everything
Disney plus is famously or you know has
not been making money and it's not
growing at the rate they would like it
to uh and I fear personally we haven't
heard any of this but that some of those
cuts could come from Marvel and Star
Wars content out we don't know in theory
those are they're big Winners right like
Marvel Star Wars countries sound great
it's like sneakerella too you know like
those are those those movies don't cost
200 million dollars to make they don't
of Limitless Chris Hemsworth give him a
limit yeah I do think like the things
that drive people to subscribe to Disney
plus families that are looking for the
Disney catalog and then you know people
like us who want to watch Marvel shows
and Star Wars shows yes there is that
like weird National Geographic kind of
Gap or like
not dcoms but Disney plus original
movies do you think they'll touch Dr P I
don't know who Dr P is hey quick
question hey Bob Iger more like Bobby
Gore you cool oh my God go too late
don't don't bite the hand and don't bite
the hand that feeds don't you don't you
lay a finger on yeah
is a license to print money we know that
Roku Enchanted wow and who knows how
this who knows how this will affect I
think you know 2023 stuff's already kind
of in production or is locked or
whatever 2024 and going forward do we
start seeing five episode series instead
of eight do we start seeing uh slightly
shorter and maybe slightly less
extravagant Marvel movies
and I don't know I'm All Star Wars stuff
on tattooing it is kind of crazy that
that like previous to Baba you're coming
back on board they were like Andor it's
257 episodes spanning two seasons
Daredevil born again is going to be 29
episodes uh followed by three three hour
documentary presentation it's like maybe
now that maybe he's like hey can we stop
promising more than uh a maximum of 11
episodes but but of course we hear it
new rockstars uh support let's do a
million episodes of everything guys
I don't disagree with you 18 episodes
for Daredevil porn again
that is the most sorry that is the most
episodes of a show yeah that I've
watched and enjoyed in a very long time
right Network TV I haven't liked it for
a long time those were 24 episode
Seasons or whatever sorry I haven't
Elementary
in season one Elementary and I can say
episode 13 by far is the highlights
characters I believe a convicted sex
offender
okay let's pivot back to uh the news
again this is the story we're going to
keep revisiting he's just announced cuts
and layoffs they haven't been super
specific about it he also announced
sequel theatrical sequels to zootopia
Frozen and uh Toy Story what have you
laid off Groot oh he's like Groot here's
your walking paper you put him out to
pasture it's just a branch from his
father yeah yeah put him at the orchard
um
uh other headlines here the wakanda
forever episode of Marvel Studios
assembled dropped today as part of you
know uh Black Panther what kind of
forever being on Disney plus and the
Blu-ray coming out and things like that
and we got a video of Dominique Thorne
auditioning for the shuri roll from the
first black panther 2018. uh Brandon
commented she looks like an infant she
is so young looking in this clip do we
have the clip I think so
and she has a great presence and she is
funny and she has a lot of attitude but
we remembered that audition
me wait guys let me put some my helmets
and so when we decided to put Riri
Williams into wakanda forever she was
the first and only call
this is her
oh that's great there's a great uh the
Black Panther what kind of a podcast
it's been on Spotify it's great and it's
tons more like behind the scenes stuff
and they talk to a lot of the creators
of the show and last week they talked to
Dominique Dawn about it and she was
mentioning uh Nate Moore kind of said it
there too but they she was like the one
and only called to play Riri Williams
she did an audition like she auditioned
for Siri and like years later they call
her and be like hey you want to come be
offer only yeah she was like she was
like waiting for she's like my shirt she
was like when one of the auditions when
am I getting the sides one is the
audition and he was like no you get it
you got a great job I didn't she left an
impression hey you come in second place
for an audition you know that's still
pretty good well I'm literally in that
same uh podcast it was just that like
she was a little too young she still
wanted to like finish her college
education she didn't have the credits
she didn't have the credits so they were
like get your credits up she went her
first movie was if Beale Street could
talk same first movie
um and then yeah history yeah I kind of
get it I when I was off for Ghostbusters
after what it was crazy I I got a phone
call as well and it was they they begged
me how long were you sitting on that uh
uh from before
we rolled uh yeah I mean I just know
what it's like to be awful lonely
okay uh speaking with comicbooks.com
which real quick and aside our very own
uh Eric Voss was on the phase
zero.com podcast you can see that on you
on their YouTube channel on their
website uh he's out there doing some uh
promotion for his upcoming uh Deep dive
uh Channel launch which we're really
excited about and so Brandon Davis and
the crew uh chatted with Eric Voss and
that that video is live today but on
comicbook.com Fantastic Four director
Matt shackman uh had an interesting
quote about casting for that film and
Galactus I think we have a clip
have they even been cast we could put
these rumors to that like just to bed
right now
in trouble
yeah unfortunately no comments to make
sorry at the very least can you confirm
that Galactus is not going to be a cloud
in the MCU
I I can either confirm nor to die
anything oh yeah
I was
um I was a little off base where I said
an interesting quote
that's interesting right like he asks if
Fantastic Four has been cast yet
and shackman doesn't say no right yeah
like which which I don't understand why
Marvel's media training is not like
denied denied deny like just say no we
haven't cast that no yet right maybe so
clearly it's being man's a Christian and
he knows that lying is a sin that's
right his nose will grow people are
weird and maybe they don't want agents
being like no you did cast mine my actor
to tell the world uh yeah
that makes sense also listen we all hate
to Galactus as a cloud but let's stop
hating on it okay the early 2000s when
they were making these superhero movies
was that about being comic book accurate
right we were going through a tragedy
how do we make these things real world
the X-Men they don't wear bright clothes
they all wear dark black leather it's
like that's what superhero movies were
and they were trying to make them more
realistic yeah Daredevil was a
giant-headed guy from Boston
who was huge shout out as a cloud it
does make some sense as like a thing
destroyed a gigantic space uh man that
is physically but like white
yes wow okay anyways
again we we patiently uh or impatiently
await and fantastic forecasting news
maybe we don't get it until Comic-Con uh
a casting notice for Captain America New
World Order hinted at a new character
that may be appearing in the film The
notice read opposite Anthony Mackie uh
of course Falcon a
um Captain America a villain but also
possibly a love interest there will be
an option for more after this film I
think it specifically said in like
brackets Diamondback oh okay which is a
character from the comics uh previously
his love interest uh Layla Taylor I
think I'm not super familiar with
another Comics character yeah Evan's
getting mad at me two different
characters yeah Diamondback or Layla
Taylor now this could still be Galactus
though right potentially well Layla
Taylor I would cloud I would like to see
that uh love interest uh explored fully
um Warner Brothers confirmed that
Constantine 2 is still in the works with
Keanu yeah there was like an article
that came out yesterday that like it was
canceled um
one of those scoopers said it's not
gonna happen don't make hot Michael the
Warner Brothers Warner Brothers like no
it's happening I think it is to use all
the wrestling parlance Warner Brothers
might work themselves into a shoot yeah
where they're mad at stuff getting
leaked out and they're gonna be like no
we are making constantines yeah and it's
starring Keanu Reeves
like where did this uh 150 million
dollars go they're like we had to make
passions
and you know in debt development can
mean a lot of things that can mean you
know a writer is off working on a
treatment being paid very little not
much money your time is being spent on
the project but it's in development we
don't we don't know but Kiana was
attached a few months ago right so like
that's a big deal he's been quite the
same when the news came out like oh
they're going to make this he was so
excited because he was like I every time
I had conversations with Warner Brothers
when they were probably like hey let's
make another Matrix movie how buddy he's
like what about Constantine too and
they're like yeah maybe did you say John
Wick I think you said John Wick John
Wick seven I think he said that huh uh
yeah yeah let him do his Constitution
and this could fall into James Gunn's
elseworld kind of category or they could
wrap this into the the gun verse tie it
into the gun version put it in the
Reeves Batman Universe that would be
funny you always call it the gun club no
um you know one thing you can call your
friends on a mobile cell phone oh gave
me the friends and I'm there uh
shout out to this week's sponsor mint
mobile but we always appreciate uh the
URLs up there on screen head to if
you're thinking about switching your
phone service we have multiple employees
here at new rockstars that have switched
to Mint mobile they got to keep their
phone they got to keep their phone
number they got to keep their contacts
all the all the stuff that's in their
phone they got to keep it they just
switch over and they save a ton of money
using mint mobile as little as 15 a
month that's beautiful that's pretty
good can you imagine only paying 15 a
month do I still get like high-speed
data do I still get like unlimited
texting yes calling okay all of those
all of those and you can keep your phone
uh all of that uh and so
um that's why you should head to that
URL that's on screen yes uh you know
because all that those savings really
add up if you're spending a hundred
dollars come on right now you switch to
get spend 15 a month you're saving 85
yeah that's just an example what else
could you spend 85 on my only fans
you're all I'm boosting the numbers oh
no it's only fan I only take one wow one
a month and they go on the ride of their
list
uh and you know memo was able to to pass
these savings on because they don't have
physical retail uh spots right they cut
out the middleman and that lets them do
business a lot cheaper but still at a
really high quality uh rate again they
have uh that high speed data and
unlimited talk and text is delivered on
the nation's largest 5G Network that's a
big old 5G Network
um to get your new Wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com break room the name of
our show that's mintmobile.com breakroom
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com break room you
do yourself a favor and you help us out
here at the show I just appreciate it I
just had a fantasy and it's a clean
fantasy so don't worry okay I'm at my
favorite Cafe I'm eating my avocado
toast with a poached egg on top and I
just ordered a fancy coffee and you know
why I can afford it so I'm paying 15
bucks
mobile lets you live that bougie life
while having a sweet little affordable
phone in your hand God I hope we have
another sponsor uh you're in luck my man
yes what month is it
uh it's Factor February that's right
maybe guess what uh based on my delays
and gains it's gonna be Factor March too
it might just be a factor 2023 or it
might just go back to a fatter 2020. no
Tommy uh same time and energy with
factors Ready-to-Eat meals delivered
straight to your door uh give Factor not
only skip having to go to the grocery
store doing any kind of meal planning
cooking whatever these little Beauties
they come already already made right
they got their little it's like a TV
dinners you ate as a kid but not gross
they're already in their little sections
you just pop them right in the microwave
and in a couple minutes you're eating
delicious fully prepared tasty foods are
we allowed to talk about Factor because
I've not too long ago we were telling
people like oh make a dinner with hello
fresh you know like make your own dinner
don't chop up your ingredients oh yeah I
can't you don't know fresh I love them
yeah we're not cheating my man what okay
this is an open relationship because
Hello friends
that's right hello fresh owns Factor
it's like an Acura Honda situation so
we've invited a younger hotter thing
into our relationship because you know
what sometimes you feel like a hookup
and sometimes you feel like a committed
relationship you know what I mean in
fact there's a little bit more in the
hookup you don't gotta put a lot of work
where's your wedding rings now wait I
don't wear jewelry if I eat factor I
gotta eat fully carbohydrated super
fattening meals full of meats and
potatoes
I had a factor meal today and it was
delicious there's a little corn there
were some cheesy potatoes and that's
fine I'm saying full up I'm saying
there's no way they do anything
ketogenic do they they do keto Tommy
wait what about calorie smart they do
calories what about my vegan friends
they do vegan and what about my tough
muscle boys I just need a lot of protein
they do those as well also also I
thought you didn't have any friends
well okay on my mobile phone I don't
have any friends because I actually went
to lint mobile before I went to Mid
mobile and they deleted all my and
replace them with war criminals yes so
now when I call my friend Josh it goes
to some guy in Canada who's making bombs
out of maple syrup oh no those quebecois
um uh sorry about that uh but yes
Avengers all of this not only is it
really tasty as John can attest he had
it's time for lunch but they're healthy
like you look at the back of these and
you're like wow that there's not that
much fat or carbs or sodium or the bad
stuff it's just kind of the good stuff
but that's probably not approved by
dietitians at all is it it's approved by
dietitians
um 34 Chef prepared dietitian approved
weekly options yes get factor and enjoy
clean eating without the hassle simply
choose your meals and enjoy fresh flavor
pack meals delivered to your door ready
in just two minutes boom boom boom boom
in the microwave uh there's no easier
way to eat well head to factormeals.com
break room 50. the URL is on the screen
I'm in this video's description use code
break room 50 and you get 50 percent off
your first box baby you're eating not
only good but cheap Ah that's code break
room 50 at factorymeals.com
and I talked to RBS so just a reminder
it is break room 50. I didn't mean to
talk about music but I got to make sure
everybody knows you use the code you
help us stay in business you don't use
the code I come to your house and I
force feed you raw potatoes okay well
okay uncooked on the show no I did that
that was me uh So speaking of me let's
talk about it all right so we are
getting very close dangerously close to
the premiere of Ant-Man and quantumania
we don't want to spoil too much we don't
want to get too much into it but before
we cut off all of our talk of Amanda was
quantumania yeah we gotta talk about how
they're going to get out of this battle
this bad boy okay because we we see in
the trailer right you have the initial
second that's right they're all hanging
out Cassie's built a machine they get
sucked into the quantum realm uh and
then they gotta try and get out of there
and in a recent trailer you see the
blowout the blowout
right uh in a recent trailer or a clip
they show from the movie they were
saying you know they're saying like you
want to get out of here Kang is saying
to Scott Lang you want to get out of
here I need to get out of here
um
we got something in common put your
contact in my mobile phone another one
let's get out here and enjoy a factory
meal I like that uh so what we know
they're ketogenic the very limited stuff
we know about the quantum realm from
past movies is that when you go in you
usually need a little help getting out
yes right you gotta have someone on the
outside that's right helping you get out
of there I think the only instance that
that wasn't really the case was maybe
the first Ant-Man when he goes down you
know what the rules
figured it out he goes subatomic right
uh to stop but but to be fair in that
movie Michael Douglas clearly explains
to him it's not a matter of getting
going in and getting out it's a matter
of getting out before you're in there
for too long and you go crazy so it's
all planned it's like you just gotta hit
this button and get big again but it
wasn't working right he goes down he's
like if nothing's happening they
established in that movie that he was
messing with the regulator and was
warning him not to he takes the blue
disc Buffs in the regulator bingo bango
he's out of the quantum realm now
there's a couple things like he could be
our 616 Scotland could be special and
could be the only one in the in the
Multiverse that figured that out and
every other one it didn't just work or
it could be something else to play here
right because MO Z you need a smarty to
get you out of the quantum realm or rat
or a rat a very smart rat uh but that
like well to that point Scotland gets
stuck down there after the events of
Ant-Man and the WASP right because and
he stuck there for years to him it's a
few minutes yeah to us it's five years
the smartphone a long time to suck long
time to be sucked uh so he's able to get
out then so in this instance right we
saw them all get sucked into the quantum
realm who's gonna get them out right so
we're wondering who in the 616 are good
Smarties who are out there that could
possibly help these people get out of
the quantum realm Because unless they
figure out a way to do it internally and
it seems like Kang is unable to do that
right yes the smartest man in the
universe may be maybe Janet was unable
to do that for a lifetime almost 30
years she was down there uh so let's
let's try and tally all our Smarties in
the system okay well I think you you've
got to lead off with somebody we know
can work these dials through spanner
right in in-game big ass Hulk is the one
behind the machines kind of
him and Tony spent a lot of time
together after
did I make this up no that's actually
between Infinity War okay well yeah they
were hanging out down at his little
company yeah because he had a little it
was like it wasn't there like a cute
little Tony's bar yeah and we know hey
he's back on Earth he's got his son
maybe he needs a little project for him
and Scar to work on you know pretty much
better makes a lot of sense yeah well if
we want to go multiversal for this uh we
know that there are Reed Richards out
there we know that Reed Richards is you
know considered to be the smartest man
in the world and there's there's been a
lot of like theorizing out there that
wherever the the Fantastic Four are that
maybe it has something to do with the
quantum realm and or the Negative Zone
and a connection there in King well it's
possible this film he could they could
run into or read Richards who's like hey
I'm about to get out of here guys
there's a like I know that this
Fantastic Four movie they're saying it's
not going to be an origin story but like
yes they're very smart but they might
not have their powers so they might not
feel connected and maybe the movie's not
an origin story because we get an origin
story in an earlier movie
you have an actor in this film William
Jackson Harper who's playing this
character named quas class some people
think it's maybe Quasar but what if
there's a moment in this movie where
like in the Big World they call me Reed
Richards and he's a Reed Richards helps
him get out of there it's awesome it's
possible well according to Matt shackman
no well they would say that but like
they cast they did Castle read Richards
and they turned into spaghetti pasta
that's true I I hope every movie
introduces a read which yeah I think
that would be a lot of fun in a
different pasta shape
hey guys we gotta quit being fusilli
about this uh and move on to you with
your angel hair and move on too what
about Peter Parker Peter Parker makes a
lot of sense you gotta go through Sony
first there's a little red tape yeah I
don't know if they're gonna take if
they're gonna allow a piece so fast
way back at Comic-Con he called this
movie a team-up movie yeah we still
don't really know what that meant
wouldn't Cassie be basically the same
age as Peter Parker could you have a
stance I believe he attended some sort
of nerd Camp nerd well she probably
forgot who he was but uh she knows Peter
Parker she doesn't know Spiderman no the
other way around other way around well
and now now Scott Lang does not know
Spider-Man right maybe he knows there is
a Spider-Man but he doesn't know
at the like Airport during Civil War
and we know we know from like homecoming
and stuff like Peter leaves like
immediately after the battle pretty much
and we also know that Peter is smart
with science as as depicted so far in
the MCU but he's not like a go-to
science genius people aren't coming to
him for problems to solve you know he's
like uh he's no one's I mean he's
Incognito right now maybe he wants a
little extra project he knows about the
quantum realm because of all the stuff
with the Avengers is there is there
another Spider-Man smarty lurking around
maybe a Norman Osborne maybe maybe a 616
Norman Osborne like maybe what if that
was who uh William uh Jackson Harper's
character was oh he's like well I my
real name's Norman oh that'd be fun
Should we run through some of these
lessons yeah a couple with the one-two
punch of uh from Black Panther what kind
of forever Riri Williams yeah and Sherry
they're both uh very smart
yeah I mean they seem more based on yeah
like technology logical development
maybe not Quantum realm theorizing I
don't know if they're there yet but yeah
they're both super smart could be like
messing with it yes I don't know if if
any of the pims or like Scotland would
have a reason to like call out to them I
don't know no yeah it would be pretty
nice though if Marvel knew that we're
kind of forever and we're getting Iron
Heart later this year a little
connective tissue have her appear real
quick in uh quantumania
spell on the team
on the team game battled battle doing
podcast writing books they could be
pissed you know who we don't even have
on this list uh what's his name uh the
Buddy of Miss Marvel
um who's had an office science College
Jason no no no
Bruno Bruno jerk we don't talk to
everyone because we know she listens to
his podcast and he might oh Bruno also
that name doesn't fit him I think that
name's a secret hey we don't hey we
don't talk about bro
um
a couple other names here uh these two
are also connected Helen Cho and white
Vision yeah both kind of involved in the
vision Ultron kind of creation yeah we
know what we know Vision based on what
Wanda said was theorizing about the
Multiverse this had his theory yeah what
did they say white Visions out there
like a a an idiot baby walking around
being like Google gaga you know the ship
of thesis they did say yesterday you
know the ship of faces the producer of
quantumania said that the uh the quantum
was the basement of the Multiverse yeah
so you know that leads some kind of
credence right is it a finished basement
unfinished definitely unfinished
basement so there's no air lots of room
for potential uh but yeah white Vision
like messing around with the quantum
realm maybe not intentionally to bring
them back but accidentally brings them
back or something now there's also Wanda
maximoff like you said okay presumed
dead or presumed she's got a powerful
brain but red powder right now but like
she has all sorts of powers and if she's
maybe still wants to go after America's
office or something it opens up the
quantum oh she's like a Multiverse
wasn't the way to do it I go microverse
and now we don't have this on the list
either but we gotta consider Wong Juan
can do whatever we want to do that's
right and he's contractually obligated
to be in all Marvel properties right I
think one could like open a portal to
the quantum wow
yeah portals can access Dimensions which
is a very interesting thing and if we
consider the quantum around the
dimension someone clarify this I don't
know tough stuff
come on the show Frankie come on the
show and clear this up a couple other
quick hit names Dr Doom I like this one
now this would this would mean that Dr
Doom is not in the quantum realm is in
our realm but like stumbles upon the
machines or something like that and hits
the button and sucks them out maybe he
wants to access the quantum realm for
the purpose of meeting maybe maybe
there's maybe there's a a suck swap
they get to come out man
but Doom gets sucked in where he turns
into his metal face you know kind of
selfie I hate this uh Victor krylar who
wrote Lord kriler on this week uh well
uh Evan wrote Lord cry live let's throw
him under the bus he's a scientist he's
a scientist in the comics comics right
and like perhaps you know he is like
under uh Kang's thumb a little bit we
don't really know what the relationship
is like maybe he's looking for a way out
and has some kind of device here's what
I think he's been working on a device
for a really long time I think nobody in
the quantum room has the ability to get
out of the quantum realm well otherwise
they would have gotten out already well
but there has been so many analogies to
The Wizard of Oz like Peyton Reedus
talked about it with this film them
using Goodbye Yellow Brick Road and is
Lord kriler like a Dr Oz character no
not Dr Oz Wizard of Oz Wizard of Oz
where he's trapped he's trapped in eyes
right and he finally realizes I guess I
can make a hotter you know what state Dr
house is from
uh New Jersey
I'm
African producer Evan a legitimate res
earch we're currently living there no
but uh okay past residence how did you
obviously he escaped and he's alive and
well now are we vaccinated you his
initial suck out from New Jersey oh my
God now the smarties that might be
helping these people get out could be
the smarties themselves right I would
hope at this point either Hank Pam or
Janet Van Dyne or hope van dyn or Scott
Lang we're like we should probably build
some sort of Fail-Safe device where if
we accidentally get something around we
get pulled back in a half you know
Cassie says she's like showing off this
stupid device that really ruined their
lives or whatever
um she does say like if we had this
while you were down there XYZ yeah right
you have to think if she's thinking like
I want to build a way to communicate
with someone who's in the quantum realm
I should maybe also build something to
like get us out that's a good point can
I can I uh can I throw two quick ones
out there one our boy Corey kendrilli uh
suggested what if it's Hank McCoy oh a
different name who is very smart yeah
yeah he also throughout Vision I assume
we threw that out before we got to
Vision but thank you Corey Kendrick
that's a good idea I also said someone
else had a super chat I can't see if you
scroll down but like brought up iron
Lads
it's like a king or like a related to
Kane that's weird uh uh so like that
would be an interesting way to introduce
if we are opening up phase five here we
know we are into this like kind of Kang
Multiverse Saga having more can show up
would be very interesting and getting
helped by a king who doesn't know he's a
king but later feels bad because he's a
king but he doesn't want to be a king
though that is something the audience
wouldn't we wouldn't know and then in my
in my last and then I'll I'll move on is
that I believe that the smarty helping
the smarties is Scott Lang himself and I
believe he figures out that he can
communicate through David delsmacian's
uh character what's his name like flu
it's like uh he I think he's gonna be
like wait a second this this creature
has the ability to communicate with
telekinetically the people on the
outside that's why he has that voice and
he's going to realize it's his friend uh
it was his name from the he's part of
the crew of the three with T.I and and
uh microphone
no it's something like it's something
Eastern European but I think he's going
to realize like oh I'm communicating
with him and he's gonna be like go to my
office and hit this button he's like
what the office I don't know that oh if
you say get two dollars for sneaker two
dollar three dollar sauerkraut two
dollar sneaker one dollar hot dog three
and one for five thank you Tommy thank
you it was xenix in the Super Chat that
had mentioned Iron Lion thank you uh see
you next time we want to shout out a
couple other folks Mikey cheers Stanley
white Quentin here for the cookies
coming in with a fun Doctor Doom Theory
Jamie Riley thank you fluffy
yeah it is Gabriel Iglesias confirmed in
our chat and uh Jordan I love the
channel love you all hey we love you
Jordan uh now Tommy yeah
I feel like there's something we are
required to do oh yes uh I'm required to
let everyone know it's time for
mandatory fun
[Music]
oh John that's so disgusting how could
you say that play the graphic again
there it is yes it's mandatory fun
pretty fun is this segment where I get
my three best friends in the whole world
together does that means John has to
leave what I actually can't be here
tomorrow
is where I get my three best friends
I have to go check out Mr Nasty Dr nasty
doctor oh you are you going to see Dr
nasty uh someone told me he died in a
chemical fire now you interrupt Tommy
here but again we tease this at the
beginning if you saw SNL this last
weekend uh hosted by Pedro Pascal he did
a really fun kind of Last of Us parody
but they were combining Mario Kart and
Last of Us it was a gritty hbo-esque
reboot or kind of a depiction of of
Mario Kart they've been a lot of money
on this yes it looks really good a lot
of speculation online too that HBO
helped them out because uh a lot of the
the title cards and stuff seemed like
they were taken straight from the show
like they shared access it's a good
promotion and there might be ways to
grab things like title cards and
Graphics we don't know uh I don't know
but we thought and of course that was
kind of playing on the idea of like a
gritty HBO video game adaptation and we
wanted to play with that idea beyond
that right yeah we wanted to take some
upcoming films uh that are going to be
released in the calendar year and uh
give them the gritty HBO take so what
you know come on in oh we got a special
guest here what might you know Guardians
of the Galaxy look like you know with a
gritty HBO would it would you mind mash
up Guardians of the Galaxy with
Entourage you know something like that
oh no
no that's what I would change the song
to that oh no uh uh but yeah so I
assigned all of you a movie and then you
guys did your gritty take on it and then
the boys in the back and girls in the
back made some really fun Graphics very
fun so uh who who wants to go first who
wants to kick this guy first she's in
the Taliban oh great just go for it and
find it for me okay
all right this is this is uh an upcoming
movie that is reframed as a HBO remake
okay here we go good morning Ethan Hunt
you've encountered many deadly scenarios
in your life and successfully thwarted
numerous threats to Global Peace every
obstacle that has stood in your way you
have managed to overcome except for one
throughout your illustrious career you
have yet to find a partner that will
stick with your frenetic lifestyle or at
the very least manage to stay alive for
multiple films this summer your mission
should you choose to accept it is to
find love in the concrete jungle while
managing friendships with your three
Best gal Pals and drinking Cosmos coming
this summer
[Music]
this is perfect mission impossible
oh very nice
wow
it took me a minute I was like I know
it's sex in the city but I don't know
what the first one is but I got it he
will kill Mr Big
oh no not the Peloton
you injects them with a heart attack
serum oh God shower I can go next yeah
and I have
um a little script
I would love to and then when you play
the detective oh yes and I'll read you
guys a little bit of the synopsis and
then I'll get you guys into it this
plastic perfect lives of these upper
class mothers of students at Malibu
fantasy Elementary School unravel to the
point of murder when a single mother
moves to their quaint Malibu Beach Town
exterior Malibu fantasy Elementary
School night a police car where
detective Ken 40s walks past a fire
truck an ambulance through a crime scene
on a spiral yellow slide he stares down
at what we can only surprise as a dead
body EMTs at work but there's no pending
emergency what is done is done there's
five women standing at the bottom of
this spiral slide he's talking to his
fellow cop
they did a pretty good job of it huh it
wasn't just the Barbies it was the Ken's
too
the thing about these ocean prints these
princess ocean estate playsets
they're vicious
play my clip
it's a place
[Music]
my only complain is I can't play 40s I
was born in 2002. oh yeah okay Tommy
yeah mine's a I guess a little more
uplifting okay but that's not to say
what you guys did was bad it's a murder
and you know I didn't think that's until
you added that at the end but thank you
uh so we open on a red-haired mermaid
floating through the water
eyes dilated no real Direction
some people want to be where the people
are
some people want to see want to see them
dancing
but I prefer to be alone in fact
sometimes I don't even want to be around
myself
we see Ariel crushing up a pearl and
snorting it flounder is behind her
looking concerned yo real you gotta slow
down I'm not just gonna keep dropping
off oyster pearls
that's flounder he can get you whatever
you need to be part of the world gadgets
and gizmos he has plenty who's it's in
what sits Galore you want thingamabobs
yeah flounder steps up that'll be 20.
a beautiful blonde and beautiful
black-haired mermaid swim by Ariel those
are my two best friends Adrena and
adriela
their lives are perfect but they're both
the same merman if either of
them found out their blowfishes would
blow Sebastian swims by
Sebastian tries to help me stay clean
but he has his own demons cut to
Sebastian chained up to a bedpost while
two female octopuses slap around come on
kissy girl
and my father might be the biggest
hypocrite of them all we see King Triton
with jetsam and floats him going to town
Thomas do either of you have any idea
how rare you are he lights a cigarette
with his Triton Ariel I'm ready to go
where the people are ask them some
questions and hopefully get some answers
but if not it's always better down where
it's wetter take it from me
oh that was great I also liked uh Tommy
decided to do the audiobook version and
just read all the dialogues you did a
nice job that was great uh okay and then
the final one here I put together a
little something I'm not going to talk
about uh it will be revealed which movie
and which HBO franchise I am mashing up
here I think okay uh this is just kind
of a description maybe a a promo for the
series
an aging leader battles with outside
forces intent on his demise as well as
those trying to take him down from
inside his own family this Shakespearean
drama of Epic Proportions takes King
Lear and pours fuel down its throat
diesel fuel oh God it's a story of power
and Corruption where every move is
critical and every turn can be a double
turn the action might start on the track
but it ends in the boardroom it as the
insults fly like punches and the cars
fly like planes okay the dialogue isn't
the only thing going 100 miles an hour
throw away your speedometer because
these brutes don't just race with their
vehicles they're battling with their
words oh my God and blood will spill oh
call up cousin Greg Han Letty little
nobody shiv Kendall Roman Roman Mia
Dante Queenie science paper and Tom
wamsgans
your whole crew until then to put the
pedal to the metal and the boar on the
floor okay because you can't make a
domlet without breaking some legs
your engine is a hundred feet tall and
you're racing against pygmies
all right every family has its
traditions and this one lives its life a
quarter mile at a time this summer The
End of the Road begins with fast X
fast session
[Music]
[Applause]
wonderful I'm wonderful and don't uh
read in too much to the spelling of fast
food just trust us on that all right
well Zach you you teased it and you
pleased we are we all pleased it uh
thank you and thank you Jessica for
popping in again she was she was trying
to avoid some of our Ant-Man discussion
because she's seen the movie and she
knows too much how early in the movie
does Kang die 15 minutes 30 minutes how
early he shows his way
King Wing confirmed let's do that off
camera guys I'm gonna find out and I'll
report tomorrow again we've got uh an
extra special week of the break room
plan Friday Friday evening after the
next episode of uh The Last of Us drops
uh our last episode
last of us after show after Last of Us
on Sundays but they're showing it
earlier this week because they they want
to give the Super Bowl a favor and let
them have some viewers so if you're
watching the last of us it's going to be
on HBO this Friday uh watch it tune in
to the break room we won't be live at
our normal time of 305 sharp you can
catch us after we'll be talking uh Last
of Us myself just in the comments in
advance and be sure to check that out
yes uh and then after the Super Bowl yes
on Sunday uh a couple of us are going to
be here reacting to all of the trailers
that are going to drop during the Super
Bowl we know we're getting a Flash
trailer we know we're getting an Indiana
Jones dial of Destiny we know we're
getting a Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
in like a dozen others there's gonna be
so much cool uh trailer content
including maybe some surprises that we
don't even know about yet so as soon as
the game's over we will be here live uh
full to our gullets on chicken wings and
pizza and I'll be I'll be looking over
countless bet slips going these can't
have all lost I've ruined it can't have
all gone bad uh I'm financially around
coming out on the channel very strong
shortly yes Jessica's got a re-breakdown
of black panther one kind of forever
yeah a little bit of it it's incredible
without ads uh 34 minutes
so set aside a whole afternoon to watch
it I'm sorry I'm gonna run a bath this
Friday so watch me in the crazy week
we're getting our fast sex trailer this
Friday yes oh who's gonna be covering
that Sally back to the windy family and
Tommy
they're gonna do a breakdown of that
with Tommy with Tommy it's gonna be
awesome uh lots of great stuff having on
the channel be sure to go to
nerdright.shop pick up oh look at that
Brandon's repping one of the shirts and
I'm ripping the hoodie our special
quantumania line we've got lots of
design times I order them get them in
time for the uh opening weekend next
week I was wearing the hoodie I didn't
know that there was something on the
back until someone commented on it and
they asked where did you get it and I
said nerdriot.shop oh yeah she said stop
talking to me Kevin feige I said Kevin
feige why do you keep talking to me
leave me alone leave me alone but so
much awesome content on the channel and
we're gonna have uh yeah tune into the
break room after the last of us after
the Super Bowl and then the next day
we'll have reactions and breakdowns of
all the tracks
thank you thank you everybody uh thank
you guys for being on the show uh and
off screen producer John uh go watch my
menu breakdown I drop down yeah but it's
a really good breakdown very brought my
soul into it yeah and if you haven't
seen the menu yet it's streaming for
free on HBO Max watch that movie then
watch Jessica breakdown that's love
knows it's there it's not the channel
takes it off the menu no no thank you
for reminding us 86 the menu uh yes uh
make a delicious Burger watch them make
it then do a double feature of the menu
and Jessica's breakdown thank you all so
much for watching we'll see you back
here tomorrow same time same place
[Music]